scott mcblaine asks hey lex smiley face
will you ever have jordan peterson on
the podcast thanks for all your work you
make my life better thank you brother
thank you scott yeah we definitely have
uh i've talked to jordan offline
a bunch of times we'll definitely do a
podcast together and i think it'll be
epic there's no rush
i think
my concern with jordan always is
to make sure that he's healthy happy and
just like all people and he's he's had a
difficult year and
i don't know i like who cares about
podcasts like
well-being health
is more important than anything else and
i think he has a
like a
heck of a crazy tour coming up
this year i actually have tickets to see
him
i'm sure he'll do a few podcasts but you
know with a tour like that
i wish him godspeed and the best of luck
and just stay healthy stay focused
uh stay optimistic and just i mean he
could do so
much good
uh in this world by thinking through the
problems of the world
and walking again gracefully through the
fire and i wish him the best of luck i
think we'll have a conversation unlike
the others he's had i think i'd like to
have a very long one with him three four
hours probably several times in our
lives
one i wanted to be a psychiatrist i'm
fascinated by the psychology side of
things so a real psychology conversation
caller
carl young
i have trouble speaking
um
so on the psychology side
from freud to young and all those kinds
of things to the philosopher's side to
the to the communist question of uh
gulags and soldiers into stalin
to hitler
it's like history human nature human
condition discussion i'm not interested
in identity politics of the day
i'm
not interested in that bickering it
let other people are much better than me
at this
and at most things but this certainly
and um
vocism all those kinds of things i'm not
i um i think those are the battles of
the day that will pass and what will
remain are the same lessons of history
that we can learn today by thinking
about history and to me
with jordan peterson the interesting
discussion is about communism about what
went wrong why
what can go wrong again
also the interesting tension is between
the the man's search for meaning
because for him that journey that search
in part goes through religious
thought religious exploration and that's
really interesting
because um
i don't even know what religion and
spirituality means it's such a beautiful
space
and i never liked sort of
hardcore atheism or obviously hardcore
religious
thought
but there's something in the middle
there and that gray area in that
fog of
where many people find meaning there's a
lot to be discovered and i i love the
the conversation he had with sam harris
about the topic the tension through the
tension over that discussion you could
discover something new together and
that's actually the best of
conversations
you